a woman some of the other woman in an
lgbt pride event of pennsylvania cheered
on a young boy working a stripper poll
a video posted by libs of tick tock
shows
photos confirmed the 30th annual central
pennsylvania pride celebration held in
harrisburg on july 30th featured drag
queens and a stripper pole the event
where the shocking video sourced was
taxpayer subsidized
i think we have the video of that let's
play let's play the video here
[Music]
now this video was posted i think but
the most important thing to keep in mind
here
and to take from that is that the video
was posted by
not a concerned citizen who happened to
be walking by and saw this happening
but uh was posted by the boy's mother
and she said she was very happy about
this and put it up on tick tock i think
it's been taken down
since then that shows by the way the
bubble these these freaks live in that
she posted this video
and
didn't expect any backlash at all i mean
she's got her
young son on a stripper pole
being taught how to strip by a
almost entirely naked man at a gay pride
rally and she thought that she would get
nothing but high fives and smiley emojis
in response and she got some backlash
and then she deleted it
so she posted it and she said uh central
pa pride had a poll set up with an
amazing instructor to assist my kiddo is
a natural
let me ask you something what if there
was someone out there who kept a log of
every single thing you did every minute
of the day i think that'd be pretty
creepy well what if i told you that's
exactly what happens every time you go
online your internet provider like at t
or comcast is allowed to store logs of
every website you've ever visited and
can legally sell this data to anyone
they want that's why i always use
expressvpn when i go online expressvpn
reroutes your internet internet
connection through their secure servers
so your internet provider can't see or
log what you do online now many of you
might be wondering well if i'm routing
all my data through vpn then doesn't
that just mean the vpn can see what i'm
doing and log my data instead and you're
right to think that many vpns claim to
have a no logs policy but have been
caught logging customer activity anyway
expressvpn is not like that expressvpn
is the only vpn i trust because they use
trusted server technology they were the
first major vpn provider to engineer all
of their vpn servers to run in ram
this makes it impossible for their vpn
servers to store any data including logs
of any expressvpn customer and you don't
have to take my or expressvpn's word for
it expressvpn is so confident in their
no logs claim they even had one of the
biggest assurance firms pwc audit their
technology
stop letting people keep logs of what
you do online visit expressvpn.com
matt wall show right now and find out
how you can get three months free
you know we hear about the groomers in
the public school system we hear about
groomers and the media and academia and
hollywood and all these other
institutions
and um it is true that all these
institutions do have a grooming problem
no question about it
but the really dark reality is that
there's also a grooming problem in the
institution of the family
in many of these families that's where
the grooming starts
and it's really unthinkable to those of
us who are normal decent people it's
like just unthinkable
that
a parent would engage in this kind of
activity a parent would groom their own
child in this way but that's what the
lottie's parents do
which is all the more reason
why the good guys
have to step up and speak up
for these kids because they have no one
i mean what what what chance or hope
does this kid have
that this is the environment he's in
this is what his mom is subjecting him
to i mean someone should have showed up
and and i get if you're a normal person
you don't even want to walk through an
event like this but
were there no
just bystanders who happen to be walking
by and would have seen this and could
have just went over to that stripper
pole and knocked it over and said you're
not doing this here
this is not going to happen
i'm not going to allow you to do this
you're not putting kids on a stripper
pole you freaks
that's what we need
someone to step up
lots of us to simply
actually
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
that wall show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this youtube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts